unsere eingangsfrage ist fast immer wie
ist die lage die lage ist sehr gut es
ist sehr kalt draußen ich friere deshalb
habe ich unglücklicherweise noch die
jacke an aber ich werde ja auch nicht zu
machen so viel kann ich schon mal sagen
weil der reißverschluss kaputt ist es
handelt sich dabei um ein
weihnachtsgeschenk von prosieben dass
wir aus dem letztes jahr bekommen wir
haben aber mein anderer kapuzen pulli
oder
super sagt man ja so in meinem super und
mein kapuzen pulli sind in der wäsche
weil der hund immer in den arm weist das
ist die aktuelle lage und ich denke mal
das beschreibt ich denke sehr
ausführlich mit der zeit das haben sie
toll also ihre lage ist also gut hab ich
dir hört mal unterbrechen ja würde mich
gerne duzen weil ich mir sonst so alt
vorkomme und ich hatte letztes noch das
problem dass ich jemand der sagt der b
75 bis 225 ist doch kein problem wenn
wir dann klar wurde ich glaube ich fühle
mich einfach wie 30 jetzt bist du wieder
dran okay das ist dann ist ich möchte
die richter nein gerne das heißt du bist
ein bisschen kälteempfindlich ich hasse
kälte ich war jetzt das glück in hong
kong spielen zu dürfen in seinem hotel
und da war es einfach das klima da ist
genau mein klima es ist die ganze zeit
irgendwas um die 45 grad eine
luftfeuchtigkeit von 670 und man ist die
ganze zeit wird man so kuschel liegt man
geht einfach vor die tür und sofort wird
man kuschelig lieb und warm gehalten und
das gibt mir ein gefühl der zuneigung
dieses kalte wetter draußen einziger
vorteil ist man genießt die wärme einer
wohnung eines tees einer kerze eines
glühweins eines phantoms soll dies eines
warmen gespräch ist aber
du kommst aus bonn bis zum boden
gewinnen ja also ich bin im prinzip bin
ich am meisten bonner ich fühle mich dem
dem der pfalz sehr verbunden weil mein
vater pfälzer war und wie ich da auch
geboren bin ich da ganz viele verwandte
habe ich würde mich den den hessen und
frankfurt sehr verbunden weil ich da hat
meine kindheit verbracht hatte sich neun
war in preungesheim direkt am
hauptfriedhof der übrigens auch der
friedhof ist die nicht mehr vorstellen
wenn ich die drei fragezeichen und der
super papagei höre was sie am schluss
auf dem friedhof spielt wir sind danach
nach bonn gezogen als ich zehn war 1980
und seitdem bin ich ich bin bonner und
da habe ich im prinzip kindheit ist ja
mehr familie und da habe ich dann
angefangen mich zu lösen und da ganz
pubertät verbracht das erste mal muss
alleine gefahren so weit alles
deshalb bin ich da im prinzip fühle ich
mich als bürger und als rheinländer
gilt ja als sehr verschlafen kann man da
profitieren und wie ebay man kann da
pubertierende man muss gar nicht so viel
drogen nehmen um aufzufallen das ist
einfach das praktische das heißt man
kann der totale outlaws sein und noch
gesund leben das ist in köln etwas
schwieriger da muss man sich glaube ich
schon wir haben miteinander die
gliedmaßen abschneiden damit man
irgendwie dass einer sagt guck mal der
ist ja mal was neu ist und das ist nicht
ganz das ist eine sehr schöne stadt hat
man es leichter
james bond ist eben so da fällt man
leicht auf ist das vielleicht auch eine
möglichkeit um erstmal mit einer
seichten gags anzufangen und sich dann
langsam hoch zu schwingen also kriegt
man schon aufmerksamkeit wenn man noch
nicht so top ist im gegensatz zu ich
weiß nicht wo diese frage kann ich mit
nein beantworten ich glaube nicht dass
es von der stadt abhängt dass man schon
gut ist also mehr erfolg hat die sag mal
leicht erfolg wäre mein ansatz
leichter effekt das ist ja immer das ist
mathematisch nicht korrekt ist und dann
müsste er die dichte betrachten also die
künstler dichter weil natürlich wenn ich
300.000 einwohner habe und habe drei
gäste ist das ein 300.000 das sind bei
900.000 leuten wie in köln müsste man
dann quasi drei künstler haben pro team
dann ist es exakt gleich bis zum
mathematik für mathematik wenig liebe
material tick ich habe mathe physik
leistungskurs gehabt ich habe vwl
studiert allerdings vorzeitig beendet
und habe das in bonn gemacht eine
mathematische union habe da auch noch
schwerpunkt mathematik gehabt deshalb
bin ich sehr matte affin aber was hat
sich dann so komme die eben gezogen weil
es lustig ja es war einfach sein aber
besser funktioniert also ich hatte mehr
erfolg in dem moment also werde ich
glaube ich an
wenn die klausuren besser gewesen wären
wenn es mir leichter gefallen wäre zu
lernen wenn ich vielleicht einen anderen
zugang zu einem professor gehabt hätte
oder überhaupt zugang zu einem professor
gehabt hätte und es hätte mich direkt
gepackt vielleicht sogar eine kleine uni
wäre ich eher hätte ich in der richtung
weiter gemacht aber ich habe einfach ja
es kann aber dieses comedy gemacht wenn
die kommen die crocodiles auf der bühne
dann kam
der pilot von switch und da war ich eine
woche beschäftigt und das hat total spaß
gemacht und dann ist das halt so
passiert also ich glaube ja und das
direkt vorweg zu nehmen bevor die zeit
abläuft ich glaube nicht an ein
schicksal oder an einem göttlichen weg
oder irgend etwas übersinnliches ich
hatte einfach nur glück also an diesem
tag noch nicht mal dem tag aber in der
zeit sind die würfel so gefallen dass
ich zufällig mehr diesen weg gegangen
bin also wäre ich hätte ich nicht sitzen
geblieben wäre ich ein jahr zu weit
gewesen für mein job die partner der
halt in derselben stufe war und dann
hätten wir nicht zusammen jongliert und
dann hätte ich wenn mein leben komplett
anders verlaufen also dann
volkswirtschaft dann vielleicht
volkswirtschaft was ich allerdings auch
studiert habe um nicht aus dem weg zu
gehen sonst hätte ich wahrscheinlich
eher statistik studiert also noch land
ist super ich liebe statistik es ist
super wir menschen leben in einer total
wahrnehmungs verzerrten welt du kennst
das linien auf caro sie sind auf einmal
schief obwohl sie gerade sind und so
funktioniert die gesamte welt finde ich
so nimmt der mensch das war er denkt er
sieht etwas
ein kind das wird geboren bei vollmond
natürlich ist es ein kind aber vieles
nach erfolgen und muss ja der vollmond
sein und wenn man einfache statistik
nimmt solche eine strichliste was hier
wirklich einfache statistik ist dann
stellt man fest
nichts hat nichts damit zu tun man ist
wahrnehmung verzerrt absolut mal sehen
wie der vollmond mehr mehr hebammen
einsetzen würden oder mehr ärzte um das
zu entlasten das hat dann quatsch dann
macht er steht einfach falsche dinge und
es gibt ganze es gibt einen ganzen
medizinbereich der nur auf dieser
wahrnehmung auf dieses wahrnehmungs
fehlverhalten abfährt und der unendlich
viel geld verständnis hat die
homöopathie die nur auf wahrnehmungs
verzerrung beruht und ja und die leute
geben total viel geld dafür aus
teilweise verzichten sie auf ärztliche
wirkliche richtige sinnvolle behandlung
und da wird's dann problematisch
ansonsten so ist es halt also was du
bist ein absoluter anhänger von
rationalem wissen deswegen werde dann
eben das richtige war absolut
eine überleitung es ist ja fantastisch
es ist also genial daneben ist ein
schönes format für mich weil ich total
spaß an diesen dingen haben dinge habe
an wissen zu lesen was mich selber
überrascht wo man selber etwas ließen
denkt mir jetzt nicht wirklich und das
kann design oder und solche fragen
tauchen genial daneben hat oft auch
beispiel woher kommt der begriff dass
dieses gebäck das ist ein amerikaner ist
denkt man immer klar die amis
mitgebracht das hat immer nach amerika
gebracht und sohn er ist einfach immer
ein ammoniak einer ammoniak anna und das
kann keiner aussprechen also hat man
amerikaner daraus gemacht haben und jagd
drin das weiß ich auch nicht ich es so
was nicht und das ist halt so eine sache
man also sinn harmloses ging auch das
rosen keine dornen stacheln haben aber
das sind so relativ so aber da gibt es
ganz viele und dann liest man ein
bisschen weiter gibt es komplexere dinge
und irgendwie geht man davon aus dass
super man was man alles nicht weiß es
löst eine gewisse faszination aus
deshalb passt es und zum ich bin
natürlich ich liebe also ich würde nicht
sagen ich weiß dass gerade formuliert
ich bin ein fan von oder sogar rational
und bekannte so genanntes ich liebe das
ich bin aber auch ein fan von emotionen
also ich kann ich höre ja heavy metal
und dadurch bin ich automatisch einer
der emotionalsten menschen die es gibt
weil die leute einfach die meisten
emotionen er lebt ja natürlich ich habe
noch nie gehört die leute immer nur
sagen ja das ist das problem du musst
mal balladen hören und du musst thema
fantasy metal anderen dagegen das hat ja
dann geht mir das herz auf
ist das wirklich gute musik das ist
wirklich es gibt nur schlechte musiker
werden erst ich meine musik zu hören die
wirklich gut ist die einfach vielfältig
ist die schön ist die ans herz gehen die
wirklich emotionen bewegt also wirklich
sehr schön wie ist auf metal heavy metal
gekommen wir haben eine party gefeiert
da eine hat iron maiden gehört und ich
habe das gerät und fand das total super
und dann hab ich mir das mal ruhe dann
hier eine platte und dann kam eins zum
anderen und dann ist man drin in der
szene ich sehe nicht so aus wie sich das
auf dem heavy metal konzert ziemlich
genau so also sehen wir alle so aussieht
dann haben die anderen sehen alle ganz
viele haare
haben relativ viel leder am körper
relativ viel metall im gesicht ja und
sind aber sehr sehr nette menschen also
ich bin selten auf konzerten so nett
behandelt worden da ja also als der
autor oder einfach so als halo und so
tun ansprüche stirn zu keine musik und
werden dem gesunden so sind wir vorne
das heißt weicher kern und harte schale
weicher kern praktisch alles genommen
die heavy-metal-fans so das habe ich
immer besser also ich bin ein freund von
emotionalität aber ich finde es sehr
wichtig dass man sich darüber im klaren
ist das ist nur ein teil des menschen
ist und da kann ich direkt mit dem
nächsten tag oder wird da braucht man
einfach vor sich hin da kann ich direkt
meine nächste was ich auch mal so
überlegt habe oder was ich für mich
selbst finde es gibt aber an diesen
spruch was ja auch gefragt wird auch von
den karrieren so hör auf dein
bauchgefühl das ist nicht man sollte
nicht gar nicht auf seinen bauch hören
aber auf seinen bauch hören ist leider
auch falsch wenn ich immer mein bauch
gehört hätte hätte ich nie ein auftritt
gemacht ich hätte wär nie zu unternehmen
gegangen ich hätte mich nie beworben ich
hatte viele viele dinge nicht gemacht
und wäre nicht da wo ich jetzt bin weil
ich gesagt habe ich habe total schiff
oder man braucht sagt mir macht das
nicht aber ich habe es trotzdem getan
und es war gut weil ich mich wohl mit
auseinandergesetzt habe was soll man
dann hören ja man soll einfach ob man
soll auf seinen mann soll mit seinem
bauchreden a super guide für die muss
ich will man so ein kalender mit zu
sprechen da raus bringt dich selber
ausgedacht habe und dass wir jetzt ein
neuer spruch man soll nicht auf seinen
bauch hören und sagen wir dann im
bauchreden das heißt gehören was er sagt
und dann aber sagen ja das ist richtig
aber ich tue es trotzdem also zum
beispiel klassischer fall ist höhenangst
finde ich sowieso ein bisschen und
gesagt seine mich aber trotzdem von
hohen türmen ab und wenn ich da stehe
habe ich einfach angst
und dann überlege ich ist die berechtigt
und die ist berechtigt wenn da kein
gitter ist und wenn ein sturm ist wenn
ich kein seil habt dann gehe ich da
nicht runter aber wenn ich an gebunden
bin und ich habe eine sicherung ein
partner das alles kontrolliert und ich
gucke es hängt und so dann sage ich
meine angst so jetzt höre ich zumal
nicht auf meinen bauch du kannst mich
weiterhin ob ich gehe da jetzt runter
und dann ist es okay ich viele dinge
würde man nicht machen wenn man auf
seinen bauch wird deshalb nicht immer
auf den bauch hören wir sind mehr das
heißt du redest
die sonne scheint das ist jetzt nur dass
glücklich zu machen das gespräch ist
dann mehr so mit anderen seite keinen
bock drauf und hab ich vergessen den
termin abzusagen oder so auch morgens
aufstehen also in der zeit wo ich morgen
sich arbeite dann liege ich im bett bis
12 1 uhr weil man braucht mir sagt
bleiben verliehen er sagt ich habe
hunger aber das habe ich morgens sie
deshalb kann ich sehr lange liegen
bleiben und dann mache ich mein termin
morgens um 9 und dann sage ich meinem
bauch stehen aber jetzt auch das klingt
jetzt keine sehr albern ich bin nicht
allein weil er möchte das so hören dabei
wäre ja wir natürlich so sachen wie
redest du damit ein bisschen hallo ich
bin der bauch ja und ich bin das gehirn
aber du kannst bis 12 uhr schlafen ich
kann ja nicht schlafen ich kann
rumgammeln den ganzen und dann halt auf
dem mit kopfschmerz wo du hast noch
kinder familie dass die ich nehme mal an
um sich ja aber ich bin ja jetzt eine
woche in berlin und da werde ich
kaum zeit haben gammeln
ist das nicht manchmal auch tödlich in
der stadt einfach rumzuhängen ja ich
habe ja das glück dass ich ein hobby
habe
was die show
ist sehr gut er hat mir eine brücke
gebaut wenn ich über den fluss gehen
will
über den du mir folgen aber über den du
möchte nicht führen möchte ist
und zwar ich muss meinen hobbys mobil
halten und dass einer was ich habe ich
mache dieses geocachen ist es
schatzsuchen und weltweit oder
bundesweiten sind halt irgendwelche
dosen versteckt von leuten und ich gehe
die suche und versteckte wieder damit
die nächsten die aussuchen können und
damit komme ich herum egal wo ich bin
überall ist platz und mit diesen dosen
komme ich halt an verschiedenen stellen
wo man hinkommt ich finde irgendwie
schönen weg im wald und dann schöne
schönes altes gelände sind bahnhof oder
somit fabrik um unsere umgehen kann und
so einfach ein paar eindrücke sammeln
und damit schaffe ich es dann mich in
stetten dann doch wohl zu fühlen bis es
auch schon mal in zeitnot geraten wenn
er abends sein programm regelmäßig das
ist immer so dass wir sagen wir wollen
um fünf oder sechs erscheinen mir dann
weil das weiß es nie passt also eine
gute vorwarnung für seine tat und auch
dass die wenn wir dann später kommen ist
natürlich immer der grund dass wir im
vorfeld wusste dass alles hervor preisen
zufrieden ist okay dann würden sich für
die zukunft dass immer alles super
vorbereitet ist
vielen dank